Transcriber: Leslie Gauthier
Reviewer:
(Irish) Dia duit.
(Yoruba) Bawo ní.
(English) My name is Elizabeth.
I am 18 years old,
and I am a second-year
university student in Dublin.
And I would like to share
a glimpse into my beginnings.
Prior to my birth,
my mother,
who was born in a Muslim family,
converted to Christianity.
And she faced persecution from her family,
who were all Muslims at the time,
and fled Nigeria to escape
religious persecution
and to fight for a better life
for my four siblings and I,
of which I am the youngest.
She tried to get asylum
in a number of countries
and eventually got a letter of acceptance
from a relatively small country
known as Ireland.
Ireland accepted her application,
and while her case was pending,
we were given housing
in a small town in the West
of Ireland called Clifden,
in one of the country’s Direct
Provision centers.
And so began the wait for my arrival.
My due date was July 13th,
which was also the day
that my father was born.
But I refused,
and decided that I preferred
to be born on the 16th.
And so I was born in my mother’s room
with the umbilical cord
wrapped around my neck.
I was actually believed to be
the first child to be born in Clifden,
as opposed to in the hospital,
in 15 years.
I even made the local news.
I guess persistence
and stubbornness pays off.
And my mom still has a newspaper
that detailed my arrival story
to this day.
So you could say I had
a rocky start to life.
Other than the fact
that I was born on the floor,
I was literally born into a system
that has been criticized
by human rights organizations as illegal,
inhumane and degrading.
But I’ve denied my beginnings
the ability to dictate my end.
After I was born,
my siblings were granted residence here,
and it was a relief for her
to have all of her children with her.
But what she didn’t have
was her husband ...
my father ...
her biggest support in the journey.
And now after 18 years,
multiple rejected visa applications,
countless trips
to the immigration offices
and hundreds of visits to various
different lawyers and solicitors,
my father is yet to be granted access
to join his family here.
And growing up without him
has been the hardest part.
So the topic of this talk today
is the need for family reunification
and the effects of one-parent
households on children.
We often spend time talking
about how children are the future
and how it’s necessary and crucial
for us to lay good foundations for them
so they have equal
opportunities to succeed.
But the first and most important
foundations in a child’s life
are laid at home.
within the family structure.
And think about it:
when you have two parents
who want to be in your life,
having both parents around
and involved means having access
to more of the economic
and community resources available,
as both parents are willing
to invest their time, energy and money
into the well-being of their children.
And so I often imagine
how different life would be
if my father was here.
If my father was here,
I would have never had to witness
my mother painstakingly try her best
to raise my two sisters and I
along with my two brothers alone.
There is not one day
I have not heard her beg God
for the strength to raise us.
Her earnest prayers have been
the backdrop of my sleep
and my only lullaby
for as long as I can remember.
She’s only one person,
so she needed his strength
to be in five places at once,
as my siblings and I all had
our different issues
and problems to deal with
that we needed her there for --
but all the while struggling to maintain
a good relationship with my father,
who is thousands of miles away.
Or what it would have meant
to see my father at my recitals
or at my brothers’ matches.
None of us would have ever been left
staring into a crowd of parents,
disappointed that our own parents,
our biggest supporters,
couldn’t be there.
And I’m certain we would have escaped
experiencing homelessness
if my father was here.
For months, my family and I were homeless.
Finding housing in Ireland
is difficult enough already,
but just imagine how challenging
it is for a single mother,
trying desperately to provide
for her five children.
In fact, at times
it’s virtually impossible,
which is how my family
and I ended up homeless.
And I remember the first night we spent
at the emergency accommodation hostel.
My mother, siblings
and I all gathered to pray
because we knew that the only thing
we had left to depend on
was God and his mercy.
It was a tearful night.
And we had many more of those
in the following seven months
of our homelessness.
And I could give you all of the statistics
about family separation around the world
or the harm it does children
when they have parents
who want to be together raising them
but are denied the chance to do so.
But we don’t need statistics
or case studies
to justify the need
for family reunification.
Because the idea that families
should be together,
deserve to be together,
is a fundamental human right.
It doesn't arise from research evidence
or government charts.
The right to be with your family,
to be loved and cared for by your family,
exists because you exist.
It is the right of all humans.
And according to the United Nations
Convention of the Rights of the Child,
Article 9 states
that children must not be separated
from their parents against their will
unless it is in their best interest.
And children whose parents
are separated have the right
to stay in contact with them
unless this would cause them harm.
And we don’t have to document that harm
to show its magnitude
and for those rights to be vital
and central and urgent,
even though, of course,
those harms are indeed very real.
I remember a time,
when I was about seven years old,
and I had been tucked into bed by my mom,
and I had a sudden realization
that I couldn’t remember
what my father even looked like anymore.
I began to cry to her,
as it felt like the waves of time
had wiped away his image from my mind.
My memories of him consisted of pictures
and her stories of him
for the longest time.
And now that my siblings
and I are all grown up,
I hear him lamenting
to my mother over the phone
about just how much he’s missed out on.
It deeply pains him
that he doesn’t know life
with his daughters as women
and his sons as men.
And each day my yearnings grow stronger
to enjoy life with him
now that he’s getting older,
and for him to enjoy
the fruits of his labor.
He was never given the chance
to hold my hand as I took my first steps.
But I pray I get the chance to hold his
when he needs my help to walk
In his old age.
As many of you already know,
the issue of family reunification
is more than just an Irish issue.
It's indeed a global issue,
and it has been highlighted
by the recent takeover in Afghanistan
and the ongoing
Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
The sheer amount of families
who have been displaced
and the thousands
of unaccompanied children arriving
on the shores of countries
all over the world,
Ireland included.
If there are parents who want
to be together raising their children,
no government should ever
stand in their way
but should instead find ways to reunite
families who have been broken up by war,
persecution,
immigration
and all sorts,
but still have a desire to be together.
We need governments to take into account
the stories of young people like myself,
whose families have been
needlessly separated.
By expanding safe and legal pathways
for families to migrate together,
whether that be migrant workers
and their children
or refugees,
families have a greater chance
of staying unified.
We need governments to accelerate
reunification applications,
and we need them to address
the bureaucratic and political
barriers to reunification
for families all over the world.
My father is a gentle, loving man
and the role model I have always needed.
He’s a man of great integrity
and a passionate, loyal advocate
for the welfare of his family.
His love doesn't announce itself
when it enters into a room.
It’s a quiet type of love,
but it knows no bounds for his family.
So ...
I cannot possibly begin to express
how devastating it would be
to continue living life this way,
especially when I know
that my father loves me
and wants to be in my life.
I want my father
to join me here in Ireland,
the country that my family
and I are proud to call home.
And I want all families to be made whole,
to be reunified,
to be together,
as is our right.
Thank you.